okay so you're gonna tell me something
about your childhood yeah thank you so
differently um
yeah first off I was 10 pounds 11 ounces
23 2002 long while I was born I checked
me to my mom two days to actually give
birth to me because I came out but just
to my shoulders my head came out and
then my shoulders didn't come out they
given her a PC out of me where they keep
you from your vagina director to make
sure you don't care but I tore past that
and they don't know what to do I was a
Children's Hospital and sunset over the
Hollywood and so after about two days he
decided that we were both to die so they
they just dismantled me and pulled me on
out cuz he had reconstructed you know
she dilated which means your Pelican do
a c-section
nobody could because my head was that my
head came out Sheree constricted she had
dilated but then she they went back
together which is she didn't push my
head back yet they couldn't pull me out
so they just mantled me they took my
shoulders apart or something and you
know pulled me on out and there I went
yeah that's a story I heard anyway and
yeah so I'm also when I was little I
don't really remember much of this but
um I mean the only thought I remember
remembering I have that I remember for
my for my childhood I probably have 10
of them because of my PTSD was me
crawling across the floor I was a
toddler and I was probably buzzed for
those people I was looking at at them
and they were all talking and I thought
I hate this part
what am I to be able to communicate you
know I just it was like a that's why I
thought I'd like I'd done it before I've
done this before and this was the part I
really hated because they couldn't talk
I couldn't communicate you know so my
mom tells a story of see when I was when
I was a baby I didn't speak I didn't say
mama
ba ba Dada none of that I didn't so you
know for the most part they thought that
I either had like some retardation or a
hearing problem or something until me
being that gigantic child I was able to
first time I was able to crawl at my
crib I crawled up my crib and I went to
my mother's room and my mother was
asleep and I'll go over like I touched
her and I she rose she sees me she
startled because it's the first time
I've ever climbed out of the crib
and I said feed me I'm hungry and my
mother got up she was terrified I'd be
terrified too
I was she was terrified she got her
lights on the house and she started
cooking and calling people that was my
friend my first words were feed me I'm
hungry
I didn't say anything until then my mom
said she was terrified I mean I'd be
terrified to of my for my child that
never spoke woke up woke me up in the
light and looked at me like this old
soul and said feed me I'm hungry
she we couldn't figure out why you why
that you didn't speak until then I said
I wasn't hungry and children you know at
your 11 Palestine houses you know you
can kind of hungry okay so um I don't
know what else can I talk about today
you see I grew up and they Carol hit
well actually its crest I am but I tell
people crest line they have no idea
where that is Muslims don't know where
the carrot is I've tell him Big Bear oh
the Helen I want to talk about saying I
forgot he'll end at this point out um
let me see
yeah but I was a little I was young I
came every sec the hell well maybe I
don't know 9 or 10 I had this friend and
she was my best friend and you know I I
lived in an area that was you know kind
of sheltered you know I never really
heard the grown-ups talk yeah so I went
to my grandma one day because I would
say my grandma's a lot I went to my
grandma and I said I was gonna bring my
friend home and we were gonna do this
project for school and her mom said I
was okay because her mom was going to go
and she had something she could do that
but evening they would really help her
out that way and I go I said sure
bringing him out fix what should I make
I said make money or good meals did one
good one so she said okay and now my
friend Andrea she was different than
everybody else in my school everybody
different than everybody else I was very
very proud to have her for my friend
yeah he's really fluffy pom-poms her
hair should he put my fingers and touch
it she's gonna be touching let me touch
it and her mom and her dad they were the
really smart people you know and I
didn't quite as I thought in the back of
my head that when I got really smart I
would change and look like they lived
you know
and because I didn't have those kind of
people where I was from they're really
smart people like her family was so I
come home again bring my friend Andrew
he was angry wooden I don't remember
names but I remember that went really
well and we I brought her home and we go
in the house and I'm but my grandma
looking like shocked and I turned around
I couldn't feel I was wrong and my
grandfather then came into the room and
he snatched me up for the first time in
my life to put his hands on me
and he dragged me to the sewing room and
he proceeded to beat me telling me who
was I to bring a [ __ ] in the house and I
was like no crab I swear ever since you
told me I couldn't put play with the
with the raccoons I haven't said him I
have inside and play with the babies I
haven't done anything and I make sure
that the wooden plank goes through the
trash can lids so they won't get it and
make a big mess anymore I swear I have
it and he was I started to cough up
blood because he was kicked me and
kicking me saying this for my own good
he was protecting me and I was thought I
was just totally baffled house was
kicking me and he's hurting me he's
pretty it's for my own good and he's
protecting me like I just I'm gonna head
to do with the raccoons I haven't played
with him I just just so so confused
about this whole thing now I wouldn't
tell the story because the other day I
had a conversation with somebody telling
people that you know everybody is
prejudiced everybody has preconceived
ideas and notions about many things you
know but you don't have to go to the
races about that you know my friend
Irwin she was black and I thought for
the her fam I thought I was gonna look
like that when I got really smart
because they were her mother was like a
professor her dad was like a judge or
something and he was just the way they
carried themselves they they just seemed
like he's very like these creatures that
were just like I wanted to be one I was
a no they were very very respectable but
they were just the way they spoke was
just so so classy and so I'm just so
smooth to me that was I was just in awe
you know and I thought where there was a
look like that I had no idea that my
grandpa was talking about my friends and
so she came up and she said it's okay
I'll go home now oh no you don't have to
go home he's just mad at me for the
wreckage she's no that's not what it is
I'll see her school tomorrow she said
I'll talk to you then you know and
that's like I just clinics day
when I was playing in her hair look at
the break time did she tell me that a
[ __ ] was a black person when I asked her
I didn't understand that I thought that
I was maturing that I always thought I
was returned black when I got to be
really smart
I was just couldn't wait for that to
happen because I want to have hair like
hers so I could play with him and I went
to sleep at nighttime you know and but
my grandparents or my parents or any of
these people in my life I was little
that were trying to be they were
supposed to be nurturing me and teaching
me and you know none of that affected me
I didn't might have a racist I just you
know it's ignorance of fear that's all
that is that's all it is
you know we have different colors of
skin because when I tries to put on this
planet who ever is closest to the
equator that darker skin to protect them
and the farther away you got from there
you got lighter colored skin so yeah I
was really bad for when I was a kid
there how about that hole because I
didn't hear the group with a grown up
speak I didn't hear them talking all
that racist answer or anything it was
just all of a sudden out of nowhere I'm
getting dragged to the sewing room you
know and I'll never forget that you know
I was terrified by grandpa at that at
that very moment I'd never been
terrified of him ever before that and he
was my grandpa you know if I pulled his
ear his teeth fell out you know it's
just I have a whole different idea my
grandpa until that moment you know and I
felt ashamed you know my friend tell me
I felt ashamed for that being my family
and I was upset because I was gonna be
able to be that I was he would grow up
and be them when I grew up and custom
art yeah tell me about your family I
think we talked to her you covered this
once before but - my mother's polish my
father's French and Irish I was molested
by oh babe when I was little I put it
all on my stepfather I didn't allow
myself to to remember that my father was
doing my mother was doing it you know so
until and so much later till I was ready
- yeah - understand that part your stuff
right well the mind is an amazing
mechanism you know it protects you and I
was young and he was Lessing he he was
only was pretty much sofa bed and
fooling the a poor Steve me the trunk of
the car to scare me so I wouldn't talk
you know and my father you know he'd
make say you have this dream every
every night for years I had this dream
where I was go into a dark room and then
soon we'll be taking it and push me down
I still this thing hit me and you know
it's a penis and then I would make me
shove my face in the crotch and I'd be
choking on it and then when the whole
thing was over I didn't go to walk out
the door and then right as I open the
door
dreamers talked until one day I hope
they're doing I walked at my father's
bedroom and that's what I realized why
all those years I was so uncomfortable
around him right you know he always
wanted have a massage I just dreaded
going home and you know having to you
know just all that and that was because
of that you know
my stepfather he was just he was a
schmuck I finally got to see him after
all those years
she's a to see my brothers there from
him I had to go to a Christmas dinner
one day so I could see him he was known
for and so I went and he followed me
into the kitchen he got up next to
behind me he's you were six here when
you were six I turn around this way
you were never sexy yeah yeah get off of
me if I hurt you and I pulled it right
out the kitchen door I said this is
Christmas can we do this with my
brother's I don't have an interaction
with you please they start you there and
then would you let's go after you left
I'm well did you know my father was 96
times my father is married six times he
had five wives married one twice and the
last one was this woman in Jean and she
she was just this she wears her hair up
with lots of Aqua Net and wore this
green eyeshadow and she was you know the
drunk at the bar and you know she she's
just like - like did he mean to me you
know she for my junior high school
graduation she chopped my hair offshore
that already was kind of lopsided and
put me this ugly dress and sent me on
off you know she I mean where my dad
walked by my father one day and he like
this come here back up put your arms up
it wears a bra I go I don't know about
my first bra was a 30 60 I have a broad
to that it was I was image from a 2x4
shape gets poof I was I had a woman
shape and you know recently had tampon
she I went to the store do you cook them
Kotex I went to the stores I had my
period was my first day
my period she goes she makes me pick it
up and she goes to counter and put your
codex down on this day you ever because
everybody that said I was just as good
just mortified to go up in and deal with
there's no sh-she I mean she was just
this one day this person said to me I'm
the head pretty eyes and I just I was
like I was smiling I had my head down
and she said him what are you smiling
about
I go nothing she's nobody you smiling
about I go he says to me I had pretty
eyes and she said that's because he
pitied you you're a freak you know that
so that carried on in my adulthood
because you know when people people say
that I'm prettier than the next thing
you know they'll examine you man leaking
pictures and so I'm always waiting for
mystery does recover that says either
shoot AFOL I'm here so you know she
bought her life and it affected me for
most of my life you know it still
affects me I still I have just complex
pet the way I look but I'm anyway I am
she got so mean can either finally I
call that my mother I hadn't seen since
I was says I see they took me away from
my stepfather and her because she I was
being molested and so uh I called her
after she wanted to have a daughter
again and she said yes she came to give
him pick me up in she didn't tell me
that she was now trying to get away from
him rain because she was too stalking
her and doing all this stuff and so
instead of a movie until I you know the
good thing about only good thing about
my childhood was I was raised in
something stable you know I knew there
was the house that was the house not and
I think another she didn't have a place
to live we had to live on the in the
living room of her friends and that was
just really difficult for me to you know
get a customer you know just I just
couldn't it's really hard for me the
harder part was when she I saw that my
mother was gay and they were woman who
the woman she was masculine really
masculine and wanted me to to talk to
her accordingly I just wasn't do that so
I took off
I had friends these friends that we were
in Hollywood so I was kind of a Holley
because like I said about a couple of
our fruit fly I wasn't a [ __ ] hag I
didn't want to change and I just that's
where I feel comfortable there
so I'm kinda you know people something I
was gay okay she could say a child when
they're when they're when they're going
up with an adolescent they're growing
and they're become creating their self
sense of self like Who I am what I like
what I don't like
well I said I never had that because I
do but somebody came through the door I
had to go oh well I asked you but how do
I have to actually survive the situation
with this person you know and so I never
created me it was always what do you
like I don't know what do you like you
know look I don't know II like that what
do you anyone do I never had this sense
of me you know and so I think Morris
talked about that one I never had the
suits with me so I went to Hollywood and
everybody's telling the people tell me I
was gay
it's okay I'm Kate and no no you're not
that kind of game you're the other gay
girl you're the other masculine whence
arise okay so I became at that's what I
do and until one day I just decided I
wasn't gay and it was really hard
because there was all these people and I
was you're quite popular and all these
sorts of things in college and you had a
good job I had a cool car and you know I
had all these things and cool girlfriend
I was just like I'm just fine
I'm just a gay I'm tired of being what I
have to be forever be else you know
video it was hard to be me you know at
me yes and um at first I had to be kind
of embarrassed of me because you know
because it would be thought of me
something else it was hard for me to be
what everybody expected me to be it was
hard it was upset so it's really hard to
meet a little too what I wanted to be
you know people are all freaked out
right not about this coronavirus meet
you at times but but it seems like to me
the immune system of these people down
here asleep I've had I've had pneumonias
they were so bad there for 45 days I
couldn't even see the light at the end
of the tunnel I was so weak it's so
drained and then I give it up for 41
days I get on my bike and I give it out
from here to you and I have to stop
after by Khalid
I just think you just couldn't get it
and I survived that I can't imagine it
be any worse than that
you know I just can't imagine how you
got past that well yeah without because
they went to the hospital I went to the
hospital because it got so bad I went to
the hospital and I was hacking and and
it was just I mean I couldn't stop
coffee and it was just I was so weak and
I had this was freezing cold but I had
this fever and I went and I sit and I
check in and I sit down else is like hey
lady you can't fall asleep on the floor
there I was like well I didn't know I
was on the floor you know mache you go
I'm sorry I'm sorry
I get back in the chair and she's
telling how long seconds later again
lady I told you guess the third time
fella this lady doesn't look at she
doesn't mean to she's seen it all so she
just has a nosedive doesn't even protect
yourselves she hits the ground she's out
and I'm sure why would you do it again
he came in that way I says check this
out I'm not so good at that stay on my
chair thing obviously so maybe you need
to give me a bed can I'm try my hardest
or tie me to my chair cause I'm trying
my hardest to stay in this chair I just
uh I'm not capable of doing that and I
got well I'm a bit you know I can't
imagine it being much worse than that
and if isn't I will care - he'll be dead
you know I have to remind myself I get
scared there are no mistakes in my
hopefully we'll all get through it right
there are no mistakes in life what's
going to happen is going to happen I
can't change that it's just going to
happen the best thing to do is not be to
care for her too scared or too angry or
too you know acting out you know just
placed anger oh I'm going through
because this is what happens it's going
to happen you could go through be happy
until then if you die you won't care
because you'll be there
you only see I mean isn't it - basically
I mean they need be like I wish I've
done that long time ago thank you so
much for talking about thank you hear
your little life story and a lot more of
it anymore
come back for capture okay
you